[Musique]
le bois des exigences au niveau
entretien que dans le temps les gens
avaient le temps tous les ans dans le
temps les gens sortaient leur barque les
entretenait maintenant non maintenant
les gens veulent consommer du bateau
avec un entretien minimum ce qui fait de
la peine aux 6,7 construira bateau puis
que six ans plus tard pour venir pour en
changer la moitié parce que c'est vous
qui au chantier naval le son métallique
de l'arc électrique a remplacé le bruit
du marteau sur les pointes au 21ème
siècle
les coques des to et des fûts trop sont
en acier le bois viendra après
le futur propriétaire a déjà prévu tout
l'aménagement la cabana va s'arrêter là
voilà près ici un médecin quand un mètre
cinquante
comme ça tout l'habillage bois c'est là
on va voir vraiment la forme la cabane
les membrures le board et c'est là où
finalement on retrouve finalement de
visuels exactement à bateaux bois même
ce même tracé les lignes sont les mêmes
évolutions fait que maintenant la coque
métallique est bien plus simple bateau
en bois voilà ferrand mesure du temps ça
vieillit bien mieux c'est bien bien
moins cher
bien moins lourd dire moins d'entretien
ainsi que du plus
on les appelle les mixtes le métal dont
l'eau le bois traditionnels hors de
l'eau le plan d'aménagement tout évolué
au fil du chantier
ça fait que 50 cm avec trois quads
écoute
vous venez d'assister à une séance de
bureau d'études le goût du monde est un
bateau de 13 mètres construit pour
l'association coeur de loire de
meung-sur-loire ça va être une tout avec
un doigt passagers qui va qui va nous
permettre de faire des balades passagers
autrement et beaugency donc avec une
capacité de 12 classes nous personne dès
le printemps à mort le public pourra
dîner en regardant le soleil se coucher
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui s'approchent
du fleuve veulent naviguer le touriste
voilà qui vient dans la région qui voit
le petit fly et puis qui a envie d'aller
voir les sternes sur les îles une petite
sortie castor tous que les bateaux à
passagers peuvent proposer un prêt y
aura aussi des gens qui ont connu la
loire avec leurs grands-parents avec la
petite barque du grand-père traversée
sur les îles aller au mori
le métal remplace déjà le bois sur les
six bateaux de marseille les aubigny un
seul est entièrement en bois il est
impossible de dire lequel
la tradition est sauvé